People ask me,
how do you define wealth?
You defined wealth when your young daughter,
before you step on the Joe Rogan Platform,
writes this to you.
She wrote,
I love you.
That's very cute.
That's wealth out a billionaire.
Yeah.
Um,
it's a valuable,
wouldn't say it's wealth.
I think not being accurate with your words.
By the way.
I will probably keep this forever born.
You should.
Yeah,
definitely don't put in your pocket.
What if you sweat on it?
Okay.
I'll leave it here.
So,
uh,
we were talking right before the podcast started about what I was just talking
about in the previous podcast about Patriarchy and what Patrion is done to a
deep platforms Sargon of a cod in what I think we both agree was sloppy use of
language on his part.
But he was,
I don't believe he was saying something racist.
He was using a racist word though it was using it to describe someone.
He was actually using it against white nationalists against white supremacists
and and saying how ridiculous they were being in that they were being exactly
what they describe and when they're using racist terms to describe black people.
But he did it using those terms and it,
it wasn't a good speech like what he said.
And one of the things that I'd said on the previous podcast is when you do
podcasts,
you're not mapping out what you're going to say,
you're free flowing.
Sometimes words come out clunky.
And I think that was what,
what was going on in the case with him in this particular conversation that he
had,
there wasn't even on his page and patron decided to ban him.
And I think for him that was something to tune of like a $12,000 or more a
month.
Yeah,
quite a bit of his income.
You know,
a lot of us then suggested that people move to subscribe star,
which was a and other platform that came out of nowhere and they've now been
shutdown.
How'd they get shut down?
I don't know the details,
so I hope I'm not misspeaking but I think pay pal and stripe decided that
somehow they're violating their terms of their terms,
their terms of service for whatever reason.
And uh,
apparently any payouts that have gone out are safe,
but you,
it won't happen through paypal or through stripe.
So they have to find some alternate platform,
I think Payoneer or something.
So it's getting difficult to even receive the generous donations from people.
So a lot of people,
um,
that are doing podcasts and doing these youtube shows,
they operate on donations,
which is
a really fair way to do things because you're,
if say if you have a subscription based service and your uh,
asking people like saved for Sirius satellite radio or something like that,
you might not be happy with the content and you might,
you might choose to cancels your subscription,
but these people can get what they get already for free.
Right.
They choose to donate because they think it's valuable to them,
which is really interesting.
I liked that,
that format,
that model,
because for the longest time people were trying to figure out how could you make
money off the Internet?
Well the,
the idea was advertising revenue and Sam Harris has a lengthly rant that's very
accurate about this that he puts on his podcast.
Ma often it's like a seven minute rant explaining why he doesn't use ads and why
he prefers to have people just donate what they would like.
And he was one of the biggest patrion people.
He was one of the biggest accounts on Patriot.
He pulled his Patriot on two days ago.
Right.
And you know,
that was a huge statement because to him that is incredibly valuable.
I'm really curious to know what Jack Conte,
the founder of the,
of Patriot,
what his ultimate trajectory is going to be as,
I mean,
as someone who will teach his psychology of decision making,
we studies decision making who's housed in a business school.
Uh,
I think it'd be a wonderful case analysis down the road.
Probably Harvard,
we'll teach it of whether he just doubles down,
which it seems like this is what they're doing because they released a statement
that didn't seem to suggest that there was any sort of possibility of reflection
on their part.
Do you have a sense of whether the market will allow him to sort of realign his
thinking or do you think he's just going to double down all the way to hell?
I think he's going to weather the storm if I'm going to be completely honest,
not what I would like.
What I would like is for them to support free speech and for them to make a
differentiation between what is the actual hate speech and what is a clunky use
of language,
which is what I think Sargon did.
Right.
It was a clunky use of language.
And I think Sargon is a very intelligent guy.
I've had him on the podcast,
I've talked to him.
He's a very bright,
and he made on the show several great points.
Yeah.
He's a very smart guy.
Um,
when he was on it,
just what he's on someone else's show doing that.
Uh,
you know,
I felt like,
and this is one of the things I said in the last podcast,
I feel like if people decide that what he did was offensive to them,
to the point where they decided to not renew their subscriptions or not continue
to send him money through patriot,
that's probably the best use of that format and the best way for them and the
market to decide.
That's really,
I think,
how it should be done.
Incidentally,
regarding the n word,
and I'm sure Jamie will now double check what I'm saying as he always does.
Uh,
there was a dean at some university,
I think out in Seattle.
I could be wrong,
that at some point had suggested,
uh,
someone had asked which book a student that asked which book should I read or I
can't remember the exact same story.
And I think the title of the book was the n word.
And she had,
I think the dean a was a woman.
I,
if I'm not mistaken,
uh,
had simply recommended that book,
but she said the word out loud and she,
he or she,
I can't remember again to the person's sex got into trouble.
So,
you know,
I wonder if we shouldn't just sort of demystify this word in an if,
if,
if people weren't so,
I mean,
we have to now say the n word.
We have to say the r word.
I got banned from Twitter for 12 hours because at one point I was interacting
with some schmuck who I called retarded,
the generate a
schmuck,
whatever it was.
I can't remember the exact combination of consults and I was banned for using
the r word.
So I mean,
where does this anime w how many more words do we have to remove from the
lexicon?
I mean,
don't give these words so much power.
Don't,
don't be so sensitive.
I mean,
I know we've talked about these kinds of issues in the past,
but does it not seem too outrageous that someone who recommends a book with the
title being the n word gets into trouble?
I mean,
it's insane.
Well as even better.
One Netflix,
there was an executive at Netflix that was forced to resign,
uh,
due to my friend Tom Segura is comedy special.
And my friend Tom Segura has a bit in his act about how there's certain words
that are just gone you can't use anymore.
And he says,
retard.
He's like,
that word,
you can't use that word anymore.
And he goes out and it's not about using that word.
He what?
He's basically,
he's not like,
he's not justifying the use of the word,
he's just,
it's simply stating that this is a word that you could no longer use.
So they get attacked a bunch of letter writing campaign from mental health
organizations and you know,
people dealing with people that have disabilities and they're saying that
you're,
you're being able list and your being discriminatory and all these different
things and they're,
they're basically trying to silence him.
Even though if you look at the actual bid itself,
he's not using it to describe a person.
He's just essentially it acknowledging that the word exists.
So this guy who was an executive at Netflix says in a meeting,
you can't use that word because that word,
it's like saying nigger around black people,
right.
Just says that you're going to get in trouble.
Now I set it in the earlier show too.
I'm just saying when I read Sargon of our cards thing,
like I said,
it's preposterous to say the n word and I've said the n word before and in most
cases I will say it,
but he actually said the word and the reason why he said the word and the reason
why I just said the word is because he was trying to demonstrate that this is an
offensive thing,
like saying retard is just like saying that he gets fired for that,
for simply making this comparison that you know,
and we're talking about uncensored standup comedy.
By the way,
this is a network that features that word prominently on several different
comedy specials in multiple situations,
whether it's cat Williams,
multiple uses of the word Dave Chappelle.
I mean that word gets thrown about like a beach ball at a fucking concert.
That word gets tossed around a lot.
But this guy saying it because he's white,
they're like eee.
Nef of your work here,
sir.
Speaking of comedy and sort of political correctness with comedy,
uh,
in my forthcoming book,
I have a section where I talk about professors who got into Trelawney.
We've all heard about the comedians getting into trouble for violating some
politically correct dictum,
but professors,
many cases,
very,
very high profile professors getting in trouble for incredibly innocuous jokes.
And actually I brought a list of names cause I thought I might not remember
them.
Can I mention a few?
The few of the cases,
so Lasar Greenfield,
who was the,
uh,
president elect of the American College of surgeons and the Editor in chief of a
journal called a Gr surgery.
News w had written an editorial a few years ago where he was talking about the
antidepressant benefits of coming in contact with sperm and other words at it.
And this was based on a peer reviewed scientific paper.
Actually two of the authors of that paper are folks that I know of quite well,
friends of mine.
And they had demonstrated that women who have protected sex versus unprotected
sex and up scoring differently on these depressive measures.
In other words,
there was some sort of protective element to actually being exposed to sperm.
And so in his,
um,
editorial,
he made a joke.
It was during Valentines,
he said,
so now there is a gift that a man can give a woman that's beyond flowers or
chocolates or something to that effect.
He had to step down from being president of the American College of surgeons.
He had to step down from being editor in chief because a whole bunch of women
were very offended by that sperm joke.
Now the,
the,
the authors of the paper and question wrote a brilliant response.
The response where they said,
how,
how could he be treated in this way when all he was doing as actually literally
reporting the data,
the findings from our peer reviewed study.
So that's one example.
Another example is a certain,
uh,
I think it's third,
Tim Hunt who was a Nobel prize winner in 2001.
I remember this one.
Yeah.
Right.
Uh,
who,
who he basically,
he was a speaking I think had in Korea at a g women in science conference where
he very in a jocular way said,
you know,
it's a real problem when you have women in your lab.
They fall in love with you,
you fall in love with them.
And so it's better to have segregated labs.
His wife,
by the way,
is a staunch feminist who's a very prominent scientist and she confirmed that
he's hardly,
you know,
a rabid sexist.
He went through all sorts of hell.
Yeah,
I remember that.
And he was joking and he was joking.
And I,
in the book I discussed several other of these examples,
so,
so imagine you would think that a unblemished exemplary career as a scientist up
to getting a Nobel prize,
good,
potentially protect you,
but one comment that someone decides can,
can unleashed a tsunami of outrage and you're dead.
Well,
I think the problem is reacting to the people that are reacting to the common,
right.
It's not the common itself.
It's the cowards that are running things that give into that.
And the Netflix thing is particularly disturbing because it was internal.
It was people that were working in this department that apparently went and
protested and they just decided that his use was egregious and he shouldn't be
able to say those sounds with his face.